today we're going to be speaking with
Dave Farina who's a science communicator
and also author best known for his
YouTube channel Professor Dave explains
I know we have some at least overlap
with our with our audiences Dave really
appreciate your time good to have you on
yeah thanks for having me so you know I
want to talk to you maybe more
specifically in a few about Homeopathy
and GMOs and maybe maybe vaccines but it
seems to me that one of your goals in in
the content that you create is to blend
certainly as we all do being
entertaining and being educational but
specifically creating sort of a
framework to think through an issue
where there are conflicting claims and
at least in principle some kind of
factual or scientific underpinning that
would get us closer to what we might
call the truth
how do you approach it what's your
thought process how do you think about
it
um well I mean for the longest time I
was just making purely academic content
on my channel so explaining science but
then lately I've been doing this
debunking content where I sort of go
after prevalent uh purveyors of
disinformation and when I mean I want to
debunk their claims at face value but I
also do try to elucidate you know what
is obviously their motive what are the
narratives they're using to ensnare
people so if I can kind of like unpack
that for people I think some can maybe
uh approach it with A New Perspective
and go okay I see that's sort of the
bias that's led me to to fall for this
kind of a thing there's a whole bunch of
um uh typical uh things that happen in
these conversations one of those can be
that the person you're talking to maybe
doesn't understand the difference
between an opinion and a fact and they
might think you're kind of disagreeing
about one when it's actually a factual
question another thing that can happen
is that it's uh Sam Harris called it the
setting of many small fires which is you
you have you're prepared for a
conversation and you're knowledgeable
but at any time someone can say well but
what about that study from Singapore
which you haven't seen necessarily and
it can sort of feel like an uncontested
claim where I don't know maybe they're
right about that study from Singapore
can you talk about a couple of those or
others and maybe how to best handle
those types of moments sure yeah I I
mean it's obviously we're seeing that
it's rampant in science politics
everywhere
um I mean I as a science communicator
and an educator I like to just find
where there's a disconnect and the
understanding and try to explain that so
I do like to try to explain the science
and you'd be surprised how how often it
is that it's just a misunderstanding of
basic scientific scientific terminology
or a high school level Concepts that if
you just get in there and explain that
okay now that makes a bit more sense but
as you're saying yes there are those
people who are very uh they like to
adhere to a particular narrative because
they derive and identity from it and
they do go oh look at that study over
here look at that study over there well
you know in my debunks I I get into all
that so let's look at that study let's
look at this figure let's look at this
character who are they what are they
saying is that is that accurate how does
that compare to actual science you know
um I like to try to get into the weeds
with it what about that when some some
is something that is brought up maybe
accurately or maybe not that you simply
just haven't heard of it's unlikely that
it changes the overarching narrative or
the bigger truth but you just aren't
familiar with a particular data point
that someone asserts what's a good way
to deal with that yeah it almost never
does change anything unfortunately on
the spot it's hard to counter because
you do have to go and look at that
Source but that's why I make debunking
content because I'm able to be very well
researched with it I'm able to I I like
to just hear what is going on in The
Ether what are people saying what are
people pointing towards then I can go
investigate those sources and 99.9 of
the time it's very easy to go all right
this person is not qualified they have
no clue what they're talking about
they're just spewing an
anti-establishment narrative to cash in
it's all there is to it um but then I
like to try to illustrate that as
clearly as possible when you're in
person yeah it's very hard I don't know
who you're talking about but I mean one
tactic is to say what is more likely
that the entire scientific Community is
either dumb and wrong or lying and
corrupt or this one guy is a liar I mean
it's it's uh it's uh it's very unlikely
that this person is is accurate in what
they're saying do you find that analogy
and or examples can be useful sometimes
in these cases I'm thinking back to you
know earlier in the pandemic there was
all this confusion about raw numbers
versus per capita and understanding the
rate of something versus the raw numbers
and like what one thing that in my
personal life seemed effective to talk
to people about it was so the United
States and
um
Lesotho have different populations if I
told you a hundred people got covered in
the U.S and a hundred people got covered
in Lesotho does that seem like a like an
important comparison or is something
missing and people go oh no yeah because
the U.S has way more people and it kind
of like opens the door a little bit are
those types of things useful mechanisms
absolutely I mean anything you can do to
get somebody to understand but first
just understand science and numbers and
data but also show how others use
numbers to obfuscate what's really going
on or to you know push a narrative
there's a million ways to do it and
anything you can find that that
establishes a line or connection that
can help you get a point across
absolutely it's a great thing to do
let's just to pick something let's talk
a little bit about Homeopathy so okay
whenever I talk about Homeopathy and I
say well uh there's no active
ingredients and in many countries the
packaging has to actually say cannot
does not treat or cure any condition or
disease period and you look at studies
where you can compare Homeopathy to
Placebo and there's uh it doesn't work
and people just get angry with me and
they often will write to me and they'll
say my uncle is a a homeopath or I was
successfully treated with Homeopathy or
whatever the case may be I don't know if
you agree with my position on Homeopathy
I'll let you address that first of
course I do how how do you tackle those
types of rebuttals from from folks about
well with Chiropractic stuff I get a lot
of the same types of emails these can be
tough because there's a lot of emotional
connection right yeah and and that's not
my forte I'll say that right off the bat
I I'm not you know if somebody has a
really strong emotional bias there
towards something it's hard to penetrate
and that's not really my specialty I
like to make these larger you know this
debunking content where I I can go in
and explain to you beyond a shadow of a
doubt why Homeopathy is pseudoscience
now some people are going to engage with
that and some people are going to reject
that and that's just how the cookie
crumbles but um I think that you know my
strategy is to go in and say okay why
would you think that Homeopathy would
work what is the mechanism by which this
could work and now let's compare that to
what we actually know about the
biological sciences about medical
Sciences what is it for something to
work what is happening on the molecular
level mechanistically that would cause
something to work and recognize that
this has no chance of doing that there's
nothing in it it's water or a sugar
capsule or whatever it is it cannot do
anything and Homeopathy to me is the
most incredible example of something
that so blatantly pseudoscientific on
face value it's so indefensible and yet
is penetrating even certain areas of
Academia you know sort of these like
low-level trade universities that are
offering programs in this stuff simply
due to financial Demand right just if
people are going to pay for the program
some institutions are going to offer it
you know not Harvard Medical School
obviously but some place is going to do
it and then that that really feel it's a
vicious cycle now because people then
can point at these things and see
there's validity to it no they're 100 is
not so
Homeopathy seems a little easier to deal
with than Chiropractic in my mind and I
think the one of the tough things about
Chiropractic is there is this kind of
blend where some of the I've never had
it done but some of the adjustments
probably feel good at least in the short
term maybe there's an endorphin release
there's there's maybe a stretching
component there might be something
that's more akin to like massage that
that that is good but then you have all
of the supposed uses and treatments and
the mechanism of subluxation of the
spine through which it supposedly works
and this type of thing Chiropractic is a
very tough one because there's so much
so much there yeah it is tough because I
don't think that Chiropractics is a sham
field at face value I think that there's
there can be something to spinal
adjustment and it's it's it's fine that
that there are chiropractors and there's
something to it but the problem is it
Blends so easily into pseudoscience
largely because you have these I mean
narcissists essentially who they're not
trained doctors right to become a
chiropractor you're not going through
the same educational path as someone
who's becoming like a medical doctor or
surgeon or something like that so they
they definitely know no less about
things that are outside of their
expertise and then but then you have
people that go on the internet and say
I'm a doctor and here's some stuff
that's totally unrelated to
Chiropractics about nutrition or
something like that and you should
listen to me because I'm an authority
and people really fall for it especially
if it has that anti-establishment bite
to it this is what Pharma doesn't want
you to know or Etc you know these kinds
of uh ways of thinking last big issue I
want to talk about and we can spend some
more time on this one you you got into
it back and forth with Matt Walsh from
the daily wire on the topic of trans
people and over the last year you know
if you've watched Trump rallies CPAC and
other places the home of overtly
homophobic and anti-trans rhetoric is
some of what's getting people the most
excited when there's a crowd there of
the folks that go to these types of
events something about it is really
getting people excited the right loves
to say plain and simple we're just
scientifically correct on this trans
issue there's men and there's women and
that's it and just sort of anything else
is kind of like cultural stuff social
stuff woke stuff which you can do but
it's outside of the realm of science
where where do you think the most
fundamental scientific mistake is being
made by the right on this issue I mean
the scientific mistake is that they
ignore science right boys penis girls
vagina is not science that's what you
learn when you're five right but that's
not all right that's not science human
sexuality human physiology is is
exceedingly complex and all this is on
the right is just a dog whistle right
nothing unites people like a common
hatred and people fear what they don't
understand so I like everyone else 10
years ago or whatever it was had to have
that moment where I went oh Trans people
okay that's a thing but I don't
understand why the right didn't learn
anything from the homophobia the the
huge wave of homophobia you know 40
years ago or whatever it was a little
bit before my time but when when Society
had to adjust to the fact that
homosexuality is a thing and it's not
boy and girl make baby and that's how
humans are right homosexuality exists
and also sexuality is on spectrum and
all these things
gender is the same way and they hide
behind all these false narratives so
every time I try to talk about this you
know somebody says you think there's 76
genders or something like this never
said anything like that it's just about
the differences between sex and gender
right sex being largely chromosomal and
related to the primary sexual
characteristics the external genitalia
and gender identity being something
that's a neuroanatomical construct or
there's a thing such a thing as having
the experience of being male or female
and that's intimately linked to to brain
structure right masculinization and
feminization occurs in the brain just as
it does in the rest of the body to
produce secondary sexual characteristics
Etc and when sex and gender don't align
that's a trans person that's all it is
so I tried to make some content
explaining what trans people are
scientifically uh and I did so for the
layperson at first and actually expected
to get a little bit of flack from the
left because I sort of defended like uh
Dave Chappelle and said oh yes he said
some problematic things but ultimately
he's not a bigot and he's just confused
he doesn't know the difference between
sex and gender so let me help try to
explain this and just the onslaught from
the right was astounding I've never
experienced anything like it
um and so in my response I cited papers
you know here are papers studying gender
identity sexuality all of these aspects
of human physiology and behavior as they
are linked to certain areas of the brain
now I'm not an expert in it but when the
title of the paper says gender identity
as uh as correlating with the unscented
nucleus or whatever part of the brain it
is people are studying this I don't know
the status of the field I could dig into
it more and do content on that if people
are interested but this is this is
science when you don't cite any primary
literature and you deny the primary
literature that the other side is citing
you're not pro science you're denying
science and there's science behind
gender identity sexuality all these
things that the right regularly ignores
that's all there is to it it also does
seem as though there's a concerted
effort from the right to focus in on on
a sliver of the entire issue which if we
think about it like concentric circles
you've got uh all gender all possible
gender topics and then you've got trans
people within that and then within that
you have
trans people in sports but that's not
even really the issue because they don't
really seem that concerned about trans
men right and they also don't seem that
concerned about all sports like for
example chess has women's and men's
divisions but it's not become
controversial if a trans person wants to
be in a different right so they're
basically talking about like weight
lifting and swimming and only when it
comes to trans women this is like the
the tiniest sliver of the totality of
the issue and it's a shame because we we
should be able to have good faith
conversations about those things it is a
problem with what we do with trans
people in sports yeah and and that's
another thing I did in the first video
where I was trying to admit that yeah
there's something to talk about here but
they that's they're not interested in
talking about the Dignity of trans
people or even acknowledging that that
trans is the thing that you can be right
right
um they just want to go towards oh
they're having surgeries on children and
this is no they're not no they're not
they're not doing that that's not a
thing that's happening nobody is
undergoing medical procedures as a
prepubescent child that has happened
zero times so uh it's it's just a way
for them to Garner political support by
capitalizing on the fear and anger of
confused people that don't want to
accept what humans are that's basically
it it's also weird how obviously absurd
things slip into the Lexicon where like
for example for a little while it was
puberty blockers on five-year-olds was
like five-year-olds aren't about to go
through puberty why would you why would
you need to do that or prepubescent
girls are having double mastectomies
they don't have breasts what are you
what are you removing how does that work
yeah yeah it's just so blatantly false
at face value how can anybody listen to
this and keep a straight face yeah it's
just a narrative it's just a narrative
that they're pushing that's that's all
there is to it folks we've been speaking
with Dave Farina who's a science
communicator and author best known for
the YouTube channel Professor Dave
explains which I encourage you to check
out Dave really appreciate your time
today thank you thank you for having me